fue en el vídeo pasado en donde
estuvimos hablando acerca de la
introducción al interés compuesto y todo
este tema comenzó con una deuda tú me
pedías prestado un peso y yo te lo voy a
prestar con una cierta tasa de interés
pero la tasa de interés cambiaba según
la cantidad de tiempo que tú te vas a
tardar en pagar en ese peso y habíamos
acordado los siguientes si tú te tardaba
un año en pagarme este peso tú tienes
una tasa de interés del 100 por ciento
sin embargo si tú te tardaba seis meses
en pagarme este peso tú tienes una tasa
de interés del 50 por ciento y eso mismo
lo calculamos para meses y esta vez lo
estábamos calculando para días retomando
un poco las operaciones que habíamos
tomado en días nosotros obteníamos que
la tasa de interés iba a ser 100% entre
365 días a eso le sumamos 1 y lo que
íbamos a hacer era elevarlo a la 365
para ver para ver changos no está muy
muy muy grande la tasa de interés a ver
otra vez algún error cometí 1.0 27
elevado a las 365 aquí hay un error
elevado
a la 365 porque son 365 días y me sale
hoy me sale una cantidad de enorme no no
no por aquí debe de haber algo raro
estarías pagando muchísimo dinero por un
peso que te preste así ni pienses en
hacer tratos conmigo a ver vamos a
calcular la otra vez 1 entre 365.000 27
4 aquí está el error yo solamente puse
un cero voy a tachar otra vez todo esto
y ahora sí claro es que 100 entre 365 es
punto 27 por ciento y eso sumar 91 y
pasándolo a decimal me queda 1.000 27
41.00 27 recuerden que la cantidad que
le salga hay que dividirla entre 100 por
eso si yo tenía 100 entre 365 es punto
27 4 % al día es decir la tasa de
interés es punto 27 4% por cada día que
pasen y ahora para sacar la cantidad
total que tú vas a pagar si te atrasas
un año vamos a utilizar el programa
excel y tenemos que elevar 1.00 27
a la 365 y humedad 2.71 4
entonces obtengo de resultado 2 pesos
con 71 centavos lo que tú me pagarías si
dejas que la deuda se alargue durante
todo un año vamos a ponerle más
decimales era 2.714 82 pesos 2 puntos 71
48 pesos ahora si cuentas claras
amistades largas y bueno ya que estamos
haciendo todos estos cálculos vamos a
ver qué es lo que va a pasar si nosotros
hacemos el mismo análisis pero esta vez
por ahora primero hay que saber cuántas
horas tiene un año entonces voy a hacer
la multiplicación de 365 por 24
horas/365 por 24 es 8.760 8.760 horas
tenemos en un día y ahora sí para saber
la cantidad de porcentaje que vamos a
sacar cada hora es igual a 1 entre el
resultado anterior que es 0.0001 14
entonces vamos a escribirlo este es un
cuarto escenario cuarto quinto escenario
el escenario de el interés compuesto por
ahora compuesto por ahora y ahora voy a
utilizar el color verde verde de dinero
y vamos a ver qué tasa de interés tienes
o qué tasa de interés va a haber por
ahora pues es cien por ciento dividido
entre la cantidad de horas de un año que
es 8.760 y esto nos dio punto cero 114
por ciento por hora por ciento por hora
ahora vamos a calcular la cantidad de
dinero que tú me vas a pagar si te
atrasas todo el año completo en pagarme
mi peso y para esto a este porcentaje
hay que dividirla entre 100 y sumarle
uno me va a dar 1.01 no no no 1.000 0
114 1.000 11 46 13 ceros 1.000 1 14 y
todo esto hay que elevarlo a la cantidad
de horas que hay en un año o dicho de
otra manera lo que hay que hacer es esta
cantidad multiplicarlo por 1.000
01 14 esto es lo que me pagarías en dos
horas y así sucesivamente hasta llegar a
la cantidad de horas de un año y en
resumidas cuentas para saber la cantidad
de pesos que me vas a pagar durante todo
el año es 1.000 114 elevado a la ocho
mil setecientos sesenta y otra vez vamos
a sacar excel y vamos a calcular lo de
nuevo esto es igual a 1.000 114 y todo
esto hay que elevarlo a la ocho mil
setecientos sesenta y esto es dos puntos
71 44 33 y 2 pesos
2.70 y 12 puntos 71 44 30 y 32 puntos 71
44 33 pesos esta es la cantidad que tú
me tendrás que pagar por cada peso que
yo te preste si hacemos una tasa de
interés por ahora y tú no pagas durante
todo él
pero bueno estos vídeos hablan acerca
del número e y hasta ahorita solamente
hemos platicado acerca del interés
compuesto y nunca hemos tocado nada
acerca del número de hoy leer entonces
vamos a pensarlo un poco porque sale el
número de oler si te das cuenta que en
este numerito que estamos obteniendo se
está aproximando a ese número y bueno y
aunque esto lo voy a hacer con más
formalismo lo que sí quiero que te des
cuenta es que está convergiendo algún
número a un número muy cercano al 2.714
y algunos decimales entonces vamos a ver
por que convergió porque se acerca a
este número voy a borrar otra es la
pantalla y vamos a verlo en un caso más
general y vamos a intentar ver por que
converja al número b entonces vamos a
hablar en términos generales como
sacamos la cantidad de dinero que vamos
a pagar si nosotros tenemos un cierto
capital empezamos con un cierto capital
que le voy a poner el nombre de p en
varios libros de texto lo denotan con la
letra p entonces a esta capital oa este
dinero inicial que vamos a pedir
prestado
no multiplica vamos por uno más el
porcentaje 100 por ciento dividido entre
la cantidad de tiempo que nosotros
teníamos y como es un caso general lo
voy a dividir entre n es la cantidad de
tiempo en la que vamos a pagar y todo
esto lo tenemos que elevar a la n iv
bueno no se espanten vamos a tratar de
regresar al caso particular que teníamos
donde yo les prestaba un peso y vamos a
ver qué pasaba con las otras tasas de
interés entonces teníamos un peso que
multiplicaba a uno más el 100 por ciento
lo podemos escribir como 1.00 es lo
mismo y lo dividimos en el primer caso
entre 1 y a todo esto lo elevamos a la
primer potencia estamos hablando del
caso en el que nosotros teníamos una
tasa de interés anual y esto nos daba de
resultado 2 pesos era el primer caso que
nosotros habíamos visto el primer
escenario ahora bien otro de los
escenarios posibles que teníamos era
cuando teníamos una tasa de interés
mensual y esto era equivalente a 1 que
multiplicaba a 1 más 1 entre 2 elevado
y como ya borre todos los cálculos que
teníamos en vídeo pasado voy a
calcularlo de nuevo en excel uno más no
aquí hay algo más voy a poner un nuevo
bueno es lo mismo que paréntesis uno más
uno entre 12 y todo esto elevado a la 2
y me da de resultado 2.61 3 2.61 3 esto
es lo que íbamos a pagar en todo el año
con una tasa de interés mensual es decir
2.61 tres pesos y ahora qué pasaba en
otros nuestros escenarios este lo
calculamos en este mismo vídeo llega
cuando teníamos una tasa de interés por
cada día y entonces sustituyamos n por
365 y nos daba 2.71 y algo entonces mi
pregunta va a ser ahora qué pasa con
esta expresión cuando n tiende a
infinito si se dan cuenta parece que se
ve que nos acercamos a 2.71 y algo pero
yo lo que quiero probar es que nos
estamos acercando realmente
y al número de hoy leer todo esto que
quiere decir que cuando n tiende a
infinito es decir cuando n se hace más y
más y más grande o dicho de otra manera
cuando tomamos intervalos de tiempo más
y más pequeños esto esta expresión de
aquí va a atender al famosísimo número
mágico y vamos a escribirlo en
matemáticas dice el límite cuando n
tiende a infinito esto simple y
sencillamente quiere decir que cuando n
bases de más y más y cada vez más grande
de la expresión uno más uno entre n
elevado a la n esto tiende al número
mágico al número que estamos comentando
al número de hoy leer a él vamos a
ponerlo con otro color para para hacerlo
más divertido es decir al 2.71 blablabla
no recuerdo que otros dígitos vienen
pero qué quiere decir esto que si
nosotros sustituimos a n por un número
muy grande no sé se me ocurre un millón
vayan a excel oa la calculadora y pongan
a n en lugar de n pongan a un millón
en esta ocasión un número más cercano a
él ahora si nosotros ponemos un valor
más grande para n entonces se va a ir
acercando cada vez más y más y más a
este número que por cierto es un número
irracional y es un número trascendente
como pi y en lo personal al pensar que
el número está inmiscuido en el interés
compuesto me pone los pelos de punta
aquí hay algo sorprendente sin embargo
lo vamos a ver con mucha más calma en el
vídeo siguiente y vamos a hablar acerca
de la idea de continuidad porque ahorita
ya se me ha acabado el tiempo hasta
luego